president biden facing a major foreign
policy crisis trying to reassure the
world he can stop russia from invading
ukraine the white house warning russian
forces could take ukraine's capital in
72 hours and are building up on the
border biden meeting with the new german
chancellor and had this message from
putin
if russia makes a choice to further
invade ukraine we are jointly ready and
all of nato is ready i think he has to
realize that it would be a
gigantic mistake for him to move
on ukraine the impact on europe and the
rest of the world would be devastating
and he would pay a heavy price
all right harold i'll start with you
you've got biden trying to convince the
world
that uh russia will pay a heavy price if
they invade the ukraine do you believe
him i do uh not only that i thought the
press conference today was was mature
was serious and i thought was direct
uh we have we have been precise
my daughter laughs and when i say that
word do we
we have been precise in detailing what
we would do if there was an invasion
we have sent troops to not invade
or not stop an invasion because ukraine
is not part of nato so they're not a
beneficiary of the kind of protection
that's provided there
but we're not naive i don't think this
president nor the chancellor of germany
is not even enough to know that the real
audience we're trying to dissuade here
as much as we're the russians are the
chinese uh and obviously in taiwan the
taiwan issue is different than ukraine
but certainly they're watching us so i
thought what came out of this that was
most impactful uh for democrats
republicans alike in the congress
because there's some republicans
including a senator from missouri named
holly who does not believe we should be
in the business of protecting ukraine
this is a larger issue and i think
sometimes politics creeps in everything
and it's certainly creeping into this
with both of the parties but i thought
what he did today was one of the more
serious press conferences for those who
were critical rightly so of our exit
from afghanistan
they are putting the pieces together
secretary blinken the national security
adviser sullivan and obviously this
president to ensure that we don't have a
misstep like we did before
you know um
it's very interesting jesse that we're
very so concerned about ukraine
but we're not concerned about our own
southern border do you see a problem
there i see a big problem in the country
sees the problem and the country does
not care what happens in ukraine right
now but you know who i blame for this
disaster
bill clinton
when the soviet union crumbled they left
5 000 nuclear weapons in ukraine that
made ukraine the third
biggest nuclear
power in the entire world so what did
bill clinton do in 1994 he signs the
budapest memorandum it says ukraine
you're going to give all the nuclear
weapons back to russia and in exchange
russia is going to promise not to invade
you
now russia's already invaded them once
with crimea and now they're threatening
to invade them again and they have no
nuclear deterrence
and they're not even in nato so that
might have been one of the dumbest deals
we ever cut i just think putin right now
is testing the west they're seeing how
much of ukraine they can snatch up and
what germany's gonna do because they're
their biggest energy client so we'll
just wait and see but if he does go in
that's going to be a bloody insurgency
that i don't think the russians can
afford well you know what's interesting
about this dana is that we're the third
biggest purchaser of oil from russia
i mean yeah aren't we interested in
nordstrom
this has been the most fascinating part
of all of this and real education for
people to look at what happens talk
about naive germany thinking that you
can
fuel an entire economy such as theirs on
wind
they they had they are wonderful
innovators and they got rid of their
nuclear programs they have figured out a
way to become complete well 52 of their
energy is comes from russia and they
didn't think that was going to be a
problem i i thought today that that when
olaf is there with the president um
basically saying oh yes we're going to
have a lot of wind and we're going to be
completely fossil fuel free by 2045 like
just like such pipe dreams in the in the
meantime you have people who are
actually really worried about what could
happen and i think that this is a real
wake-up call for america as well to
think about our own energy independence
and the policies that we are putting in
place it takes a long time for these
companies to invest in order to go after
more energy and if you had this when you
had the change in administration that's
one of the first things that they
signaled is that america wants to be
like germany when it comes to energy and
as for me no thank you i do not want
that at all the press conference today
was a lot better than the one he had
before when he said minor incursion is
cool yeah and so maybe that will help i
also i give them
i will say they are obviously much more
organized and for coming with
information than they were on
afghanistan yeah for sure that's a low
bar
and i know low bars
oh you do all right well you know what
but but in terms of of germany and in
terms of their you know not really being
a part of nato or so it seems they're
not a part of nato the truth is that
jen sake when asked a question started
talking about the fact that you know we
want to be a leader in green energy and
you know we really can't be worried
about oil and fossil fuels right now i
mean except that's how we're living
that's how we live and we were we were
pretty damn close to being energy
independent and that became and the
whole point of being let's say less
involved in the middle east that was our
that's that's how we got to that stage i
uh jesse brought up an interesting point
if if we do nothing and russia invades
no one's ever going to give up their
nukes again they might i mean like if
you go to if you could be yeah
yeah if you go to north korea and you go
nick i'm not giving him up now i'm going
to say something really i don't i don't
know much about what's going on my my
mother-in-law is in calve right now so
i'm worried but has anybody did you send
her to kiev
you saw out just yet
well she's not watching so she didn't
hear that joke but yes i did
but has any has anyone asked putin
publicly or any or just what he wants
and i missed it like what does he want
ukraine not to be admitted to nato fine
then done we're good like what do i care
but
go ahead go ahead
and then you always ask for something
more yeah yeah but he wanted crimea and
no one said anything
when does it stop then because that's
the challenge does china look at this uh
it was george h.w bush and and you're
going to blame bill clinton it was h.w
bush also that agreed for still signed
it but
but but but what's history but my only
point what's going to what would he take
next i mean he wants to reconstitute hit
the his greatest greatest desire putin
is to reconstitute the ussr
do we want the beginning blocks of it i
don't and i just think it's not it's not
partisan would be the would it what is
it something like us deciding that uh
trying to think of an out like us
putting troops on the on right on cuba i
mean it's like cuba was never part of
our country ukraine was a part of their
so anyway you know it's a big thing
i'm more sympathetic to russia than i
guess so you're saying we should invade
canada is that what you're saying that's
what i had today
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else